get five suggestions we will do a wrap
it will be delightful people in this
section here what would you like a rap
about
pyramids pyramids
sometimes i said why
let me ask this why pyramids
that's pretty good okay so the
suggestion is in pyramid the suggestion
is pyramids are a great shape i like
that thank you let's come to this kind
of trapezoidal we're gentle right here
[Music]
yeah
no one's debating that pyramids are a
great shape destiny's child if you are
in this area
so meghan markle's coming
[Laughter]
would you um please describe this dick
and don't be too obvious
[Laughter]
would you would you repeat what you said
it was really good
i
[Applause]
[Music]
we know what you said
no no because there it was it was there
was a specific there was some real
descriptors there
he said
it was prefaced by the words nine inches
long and girthy
i don't know why you're hiding that like
suddenly you were like kind of what i
feel with i didn't shoot for the moon
with a 12.
someone wants a 12.
it was random no it was very specific
it was i need some describing words
today nine inches long and girthy
and there's nothing wrong with knowing
what you're like that's fine
so a dick which is nine inches long and
girthy pyramids are a great shape
destiny's child i would like two more
suggestions knowing full well that
neither of them are going to be as
delightful
but i haven't asked at this area what
would you like a rap about
an anxious dentist was that yeah lovely
there's a lovely um
internal running for that yeah
i was trying to think of the correct
linguistic term but i cannot for the
life to meet it's quite late one final
suggestion this come from anywhere what
would you like a rap about
kindergarten tinder dates a11
there's nothing shameful about that
okay tinder dates um
let's this is the tackle okay cool well
this is gonna be a wrap that's a
freestyle made up on the spot oh my god
i think it knew me every show this one's
really fast and uh it might be too low
but let's let's try so this is a wrap
based on those suggestions pyramids are
a great shape uh nine inches long girthy
destiny's child tinder dates and an
anxious dentist and then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
pyramids that's the creation you said it
before three points in the cloud goes
wild three ladies in destiny's childhood
[Applause]
[Music]
beyonce
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but right among us someone's like i got
that hunger for the perfect words i
deserve these wanna get the nice length
wanna get the girthy girthy is basically
delaying it around what's the diameter
what have you found three times
[Music]
your hands are shaking he's just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Applause]